it is a new fight for the military
soldiers now wearing the uniform of
protection in the battle against a virus
which has already claimed the lives of
thousands of people in the capital
Madrid the epicentre of Spain's crisis
military teams ventured into care homes
to disinfect the properties the
country's overwhelmed hospitals have
asked homes to look after seriously ill
people but the site's lacked
sophisticated machinery and there are
reports of bodies being found in some
premises when the military went in there
are many people over 70 years here in
Madrid there are many people in their
residences and in fact we are a great
problem to control the virus and to
control to reduce the dates in the
residence so many have died in the
capital that an ice-rink is being used
as a temporary morgue to store bodies
hearses arrives throughout the day
hospitals are overwhelmed with patients
queuing in corridors to be seen but it's
not just the elderly now succumbing to
the virus 41 year old Oliver Camerino
posted warnings to friends after being
admitted to intensive care in Barcelona
with coronavirus he's now recovering at
home from where we spoke to him when I
was in the hospital doctors told me that
there were a few other young guys in the
hospital even younger than I was healthy
guys and there were in intensive care as
well and it's upsetting ie
I also a discussion with friends who
still now are telling me that you know
when you see news or younger people
getting sick is just anecdotal that it
doesn't really happen to everyone and
it's very frustrating because if the can
only experience one day or what I
experienced for 10 days they will
definitely change their mind a vars
conference center in Madrid is being
transformed into a 5,500 bed hospital to
treat coronavirus patients doctors in
Spain say whilst emergency equipment is
coming through the sheer numbers needing
treatment is
Challenge I think that we have all the
different coding and we have all the
material to come I think our patient but
the it's a very difficult situation in
in our public sanitary system the
doctors and nurses are buoyed by the
success stories from their efforts here
cheering the first patient to be
released from a field hospital in the
capital her medical staff also
applauding the residents who have obeyed
the order to stay indoors a lockdown in
force for weeks yet in an effort to stop
the virus spreading further
Michelle Clifford Sky News Brussels